Hey it's me, Destin.
So, um... we don't have
really awseome accents
and we don't have a lot of money,
but we do know our guns.
And we are rocket scientists.
So, we're gonna start a new web
series called Smarter Every Day.
[Music]
Uh, we're gonna try to teach you
something about twice a week.
Today we have the Saiga-12
with a 20-round mag.
So we're going to teach you the difference
between a detonation and a deflagration.
A detonation is something that is sonic.
You have a shockwave or a
disturbance in the air.
A deflagration is something
that is subsonic.
So basically it's just a rapid
oxidation, but there's no shockwave.
So that's what we're going to demonstrate.
Let's make this science official.
With Goggles.
Here we go.
[Cocking]
Alright.
[Successive gunshots]
[Slow motion gunshots]
Well, looks like our flame went out on one.
[Successive gunshots]
But it's still pretty fun.
Saiga-12, 20-round mag, double-ought buck.
It's worth the price of admission.
[Unloading]
Anyway, just remember: in the
end, it's all gonna burn.
Or... at least deflagrate. Now that you
know the word, right? Have a good one.
Captioning in different languages welcome.
Please contact Destin if you can help.